بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
نقول الله تعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من
الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
قوله تعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا
وهذا الاسلوب يدل على
تحريم لما سياتي
فان الاجتناب اشد
ومن اشد اساليب التحريم في القران
ومعنى الاجتناب ان يكون هذا المحرم في
جانب
والمؤمن في جانب مضاد في جانب اخر
يقول يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا
من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم وهذا فيه احتياط
فان الانسان
الذي يوقع في الاثم يعني في الحرام الذي
هو محرم من من الظنون
فانه بعض الظن
ولكن الله تعالى نهان عن كثير من الظن
رغم ان
بعض الظن اثم
احتياطا باننا اذا اجتنبنا
ما علمناه
اثما وما
خشينا ان يكون اثما
فاننا لا نقع في ما حرم الله سبحانه
وتعالى من الظنون
والظن
في هذا
المكان من القران
وفي هذا السياق
يطلق ويراد به
ضد اليقين
ضد العلم
يعني
الظن يطلق ويراد به العلم ويراد به اليقين
الذين يظنون انه ملاقوا ربهم
ويطلق ويراد به الشك يراد به ما دافعه
الهوى
مثل قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
هنا اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن
اثم ان يتبعون الا الظن وانهم الا يخرسون
وان الظن لا يغني من الحق شيئا هذه الايات
الظن يطلق ويراد به
ما لا يسند الى علم
ضد العلم
ضد اليقين
ضد الراجح
هذا
يقصد به
الظن يطلق في هذا المجال ويقصد به ضد
الراجع ضد العلم ضد اليقين
اتباع الظن
محرم
لان
الانسان لا يتبع الظن
بهذا المعنى الا اذا كان له هوى
الذي يدفعه لاتباع الظن
يعني مثلا
الانسان
ان اراد
ان
يسند الى شيء وان يعرج على شيء فانه يعرج
على غالب الظن على الراجح على اليقين على
العلم
ولا يذهب الى ما هو ظن
ويعرج عليه في مقابل العلم الا
اذا كان الذي يدفعه الى ذلك الهوى
فمثلا
الظن السيء
بالاخ المسلم
ظاهره الصلاح
واتباع الديانه
لا يفعل
الفواحش ظاهرا هل من الممكن ان يعمل من
الكبائر في الخافه ممكن
صح ولا لا ممكن
هل هو شغلك ولا شغلي لا
وبيني وبين الله
ربنا سبحانه وتعالى هو الذي خلقه والذي
يراه وهو الرقيب عليه
مش شغلي انا
الذي يظهر لي
ان ظاهره الصلاح ظاهره
خوف الله سبحانه وتعالى
الظاهر محبه الاسلام
والله اعلم بما في القلوب
لكن
هذا الذي ظاهره الصلاح
ابتدئ اظن به الظنون
الظنون السيئه هل هو ظاهره
اعلمني
بشيء من هذه
الامور التي انا اتهمه بها في نفسي الجواب
لا ما الذي يدفع الانسان ليظن خلاف الظاهر
بالباطن الغالب الهوى
واحد بيغار من الثاني
بيغار منه لكن
الحسد الحسد
ما ذمه
الحاسد لا يعترف انه حاسد صح ولا لا
الحاسد والذي يحسد الغير
ولا يعترف انه يحسد غيره لماذا لانها مذمه
اجمعت العقول على ان هذا هذا ليس من شيم
اهل العقول السليمه
مثل الكذب
الكذاب لا يعترف انه كذاب ولا يعترف انه
يكذب ويرى ان هذه مذمه ونفس الشيء الحسد
ولا يعترف الحاسد انه يحسد غيره
وانه عنده يعني
حسن لغيره
فيريد ان يبطش بهذا الغير يريد ان يخفي
على نفسه هو انه حاسد لانني
الانسان اذا حسدت غيري هذا يعني انني
اعترف
اذا اعترفت انا انني حسبت غيري فهذا
الاعتراف يدل على انني اعترفت بانني اضعف
من فلان
وخير مني في مجال او في
الغالب او ما شابه اكثر الناس لا يريد ان
يعترف بمثل هذا ويابى ذلك
فياتي
بالاشياء التي يعلل بها كلامهم
فيبتدا ينظر الى اشياء هي
لها تفاسير كثيره
فيؤولها على اسوا الاحوال
الام ظاهره كذا
وقد يراد به الشر
فهو يذهب الى الشر مع ان الظاهر والغالب
على الظن عكس ذلك ما الذي دفعه الى ذلك
الحسد
ما الذي دفعوا الى ذلك الهوى
فان
الذي
يتهم من حوله
بالظنون السيئه
فان هذا
يغلب عليه الهوى يغلب عليه الهوى
يغلب عليه الضعف في الشخصيه والشيطان
الشيطان يريد ان يبث هذه الظنون بين الناس
بين المؤمنين
رسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
يائس الشيطان ان يعبده المصلين في جزيره
العرب ولكن بالتحريش التحريش يعني طمعه في
ايقاع ورد
المؤمنين الى
الى السوق بعد ان
استقاموا على الخير بماذا بالتحريش بينهم
وهذا التحريج بدايته الظن السيء
ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عالج
هذه الامور من جذورها فقال
اوحي الي ان تواضعوا تواضعوا
حتى لا يفخر احد على احد
فهذا الظن السيء
الظن السيء الذي نهى الله سبحانه وتعالى
عنه هو بعض الظن الاثم هو الذي لا يستند
الى دليل ظاهر او لا يستند الى غلبه الظن
وانما يستند الى الهوى ويغلب عليه السوء
والظن
انواع ظن الانسان بالله سبحانه وتعالى ظن
الانسان بالرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
بالصحابه
باخوانه المؤمنين باهله وهكذا
الظن الذي
يستند الى دليل صحيح
مفهوم على وجهه فهذا ليس اثما هذا ما يؤدي
اليه العلم
ولكن الظن الذي هو اثم
هو الذي يكون مبناه الهوى ولا يستند الى
دليل
ولا يستند الى دليل
فيعقوب عليه السلام
لما اخبره
يوسف عليه السلام اني رايت احد عشر كوكبا
والشمس والقمر
رايتهم لي ساجدين
ماذا قال له قال لا تقصص رؤياك على اخوتك
فيكيد لك كيدا طيب هذا يقين ولا ظن
لكن هل هذا اثم ليس اثم لانه يستند الى
دليل
وفيه دافع لي
دافع للمفسده
يعني هو صحيح هؤلاء اخوه يوسف عليه السلام
وهو يحبهم لانهم ابناؤه وظاهرهم الصلاه
لكن يعقوب عليه السلام علم منهم
كما ان الوالد يعلم ويعرف في اولاده ما
يعرف
فهو اوصى يوسف عليه السلام
ليس انتقاما منهم وانما اضطرارا الى
الحفاظ على يوسف عليه السلام وقال له ذلك
هذا الظن هل هذا الظن كان يثما لا لانه
كان يستند الى دليل وكان بضروره
لكن الظن الذي لا يستند الى دليل هذا هو
الظن الذي ذمه الله سبحانه وتعالى في
القران
وجعله مقابلا للعلم
او الظن الذي
يستند الى
ارتياح النفس الى هذا الشيء
فمثلا بعض الناس يظن السوء بالله سبحانه
وتعالى ودائما يظن السوء بالله ولا ولا
يتفائل
لا يتفائل
وهذا امر محرم الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول
لا يموتن احدكم الا وهو يحسن الظن بالله
عز وجل
لكن بعض الناس يعظم نفسه
ويظن ان له حقا لم يوفي به الله سبحانه
وتعالى
فيظن السوء بالله وهذا يعود الى نفسيه
اليهود
قالت اليهود يد الله مغلوله
ليش ما يعطيني ليش اعطى فلان انا بستاهلش
انا مش احسن من فلان
وهذه الظنون
اردته والعياذ بالله
ظنوا بالله سبحانه وتعالى على الرغم من
هذه النفسيه الخبيثه قالوا لا تمسنا النار
الا اياما
معدودهم في دينهم ما كانوا يفترون
ذلك الظن بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
والصحابه بعض الناس يظن السوء كيف
يظن مثلا ان الصحابه كانوا جماعه
جماعه هيك بس ماشيين على الظهر وجماعه على
البركه ما كان يعني بعض العلماء والعياذ
بالله من المتاخرين حتى قالوا هذا الكلام
صراحه
ولون طريق السلف اسلم طريق الخلف اعلم
واحكم هذا الكلام الباطل
فيقول
الخلف هم اللي بحثوا لكن الصحابه الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم كانوا بس يتقبل وخلاص
قبول قلوبهم هيك سبحان الله لكن اللي اجوا
بعد
عقولهم من قوه العقل اللي عندهم لازم
يبحثوا لازم يتوصلوا لا
كلام غلط تماما
العكس هو الصحيح
الذي منع
وحجز النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم والصحابه
وجعلهم يتوقفون حيث توقفوا وعلمهم والحكمه
وهو ورعهم ومعرفتهم بنفسهم
ومعرفتهم بالله
كم تجد في القران
الله عز وجل يقول ويسالونك ويسالونك
ويسالونك ويسالونك عن المحيض هو مش بس
النساء الرجال سالوا عن المحيض
لكن اين تجد في القران
ويسالونك عن صفه الله كذا وكذا كيف استوى
الله على العرش كيف يفعل الله كذا كيف
يضحك الله ان الله ضحك الى اثنين يقتل
احدهم الاخر يدخلان الجنه كيف يا رسول
الله هذا كلام يسال هذا هذا هل هذا يسال
من الادب
يقال كيف يفعل الله كذا وكذا
ورب العالمين لا يحتاج الينا ان نحل له
هذه القصه
ويفعل انت تصدق وتؤمن وتلتزم حدك تعبت انا
عبد
فهذه الافكار
روجوا بها ماذا
روجوا بها
وهذه زله حتى لبعض لبعض العلماء في تاريخ
الاسلام
بعضهم وهم قله الحمد لله ذلوا بهذا الفكر
مع ما عنده من العلم والخير والخوف من
الله المحبه لله سبحانه وتعالى الا انهم
اغتروا
روجوا بهذا الفكر بعض البدع على المسلمين
لان اهل السنه يقولون انتم تبحثون هذه
المباحث والحق انها
لا يمكنكم ان تتوصلوا الى شيء فيها لان
الله سبحانه وتعالى قد اخبرنا بما يكفينا
الصحيح ان توقف حيث توقف القوم
الصحابه والرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
توقفوا عن هذا البحث لماذا لم يبحثوا فهو
بده يروج بدعته فماذا يقول
طريق
سلف اسلم وطريق الخلف اعلم
هذا الكلام الكلام باطل
هذا كلام باطل
لكن
هذا الكلام قاله بعض من قاله
واغتار به من اغتر
والتوبس عليه امره من التوبس بهذا الكلام
وهذا ياتي من ظن ما هو الظن ان الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم والصحابه كانوا يعني جماعه
درويش يلحق وراء السخله ويلحق وراء البقره
يعني فكره ضيق وافقه ضيق وما ما خرجوا الى
الدنيا ولا عرفوا
الامور الخارجه ما بعرف الا البقره وبيعرف
بس الجمل والناقه والجبل
وبس يعني جماعه على سلامتهم كلام هذا
كلامهم هذا ظنهم بالرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
انهم جماعه ما بحثوا في هذه الاشياء ولا
تجراوا عليها لانها اصلا ما خطرتش لهم على
ذلك
لانه الجماعه افوقهم ضيق هذا كلام يقال
لا باس السلف
اذا
وبعضهم يقول لا
كانوا جماعه مشغولين به
الجهاد والطاعه
وما خطر في بالهم منهم اصلا يتساءلوا هذا
التساؤل
غلط
هم حيث وقفوا وقفوا عن علم
وصلوا الى نهايه ما ينبغي فوقفوا
ولو كانوا ما خطر على بال حدا منهم انهم
يسال وكان لازم نعرف كان ربنا اخبرنا بدون
ما هم يسالوا صح ولا لا كم من شيء مذكور
في القران لم يسال عنه احد وانزله الله
سبحانه وتعالى ابتداء
ولكن هذا مثل
ويسالونك عن الروح قل الروح امر ربي
وما اوتيت من العلم الا قليلا يعني انتم
ختمتوا كل العلوم مش لاكين غير هذه تسالوا
عنها
هذا سوء ادب وسوء ظن الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم الصحابه
وهذه الظنون منتشره في المسلمين خاصه في
هذا الزمان لماذا
للاستعمار لسبب الاستعمار الاستعمار
الفكري الذي عمه الامه الاسلاميه الا من
رحم الله
فاصبح المسلمون
اصبحوا
اذنابا
لغير المسلمين واصبحوا
يستحيون من تاريخهم ويفخرون من
الاخرين
وكان كما اخبر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ولا ينزعن الله
الرهبه منكم من صدور اعدائكم
ولا يلقىن في صدوركم الوهن قالوا ما الوهن
قال حب الدنيا
وكراهيه الموت
هذا واقع ولا مش واقع يعني صراحه خلينا
نكون صريحين مع انفسنا
هل عدونا ومستعمرنا يخشانا لا يخشانا
ذهبت هذه الرهبه مع ان اسلافنا كان
عدوهم يخافهم مسيره شهر مسيره شهر
يعني تصورها هذه مسيره شهر يعني
خرج الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
الى
بعض اعدائه
فسمعوا بخروجه ودشروا المدينه كلها مفتوحه
وجردوا وقالوا محمد والجند
وهربوا وخلوله المدينه كلها
هذا شيء طبيعي يعني
رعب غير شكل
غير طبيعي
لكن على كل حال
هذه من هذا
فهذا السوء الظن اتسرب على كثير من
المسلمين من حيث لا يشعرون
والمسلمون كثيرا من هذه الامور لا
يستشعرون بها لماذا
لان هذا الاستعمار الفكري قتل النفسيه
والروح
الاسلاميه
وكثير من المسلمين يجهل تاريخه وليس هذا
لانهم اهل سوء لا بل لان عدوهم حريص حريص
على
على جهلهم وحريص على نزع الثقافه من بينهم
وحريص على سجن العلماء
واسكات العلماء
حريص على الحرب على علماء المسلمين
والمسلمون اذا علماؤهم ما يستطيعوا
يتكلموا
جماعه منهم
مسجون وجماعه مشترى ماذا ماذا يصنعون
راح ولا لا
فهذا
بالصوت
وهذا
بالدرهم
والاخير نادر لكن يحصل
اين يذهب المسلمون ومن وانا لهم ان
يدافعوا عن عقائدهم وان يعلموا الصح من
الغلط لازم احنا يبقى عنا ناس مختصين
بالعلوم الشرعيه عندهم تقوى من الله
وعندهم شجاعه يقومون مقام غيرهم بالكلام
وانه لا يوازي
دماء الشهداء الا مداد العلماء هذا معروف
والشهداء
لم ياتوا ولم يذهبوا لولا اهل العلم اهل
العلم
رغبوهم واوصلوا اليهم الرساله وصوروها لهم
وعرفوهم بها
فعلى كل حال هذا الظن ينتشر بين الناس وقد
لا يشعر احدنا بان عنده هذا الظن
فياتي شيء من امر الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم او ياتي شيء من البدع
وتعرض
لاحدنا
فيسبق له هذا
سوء الظن الذي هو لا يتفطن اليه قد يكون
لا شعوريا
فيظن هذا السوء
بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم واصحابه
انهم جماعه ماتمحصوا العلم ولا عرفوا
العلم سمعنا واطعنا انه ضعف ليس ضعفا هذا
هذه قوه
وكذلك سوء الظن بالاخ او الزوجه الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ذكر ان
من
الظن او من الغيره الغيره غيرتان غير بحق
وغير
دون ريبه اذا ما في ريبه
ويغار فهذا غيره يبغضها الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ياتي
هذا ويقول انا زلمه بغار يقعد يتهم اهله
باشياء لا ينبغي ولا يجوز له ان يفعل
ويزعم ان جراء هذا انه من
غيرته يعني هذا جاء من جراء غيرته
حماسته ومحبته لا ان من الغيره ما قد يكون
من الجنون ويكون من ضعف الشخصيه
يصبح هذا يتهم الناس بدون اي مستند بدون
اي ظاهر
وهكذا اتهام الصالحين
ببعض الذنوب او بعض الاحوال الخبيثه
ان هذا اثم هذا اثم
ويسميه بعض العلماء كثير من العلماء
الغيبه النفسيه يعني تغتاب اخاك لنفسك
بهذا الظن السوء وهذا الظن ان استقر في
القلب
فانه لا يلبث الا ان يؤتي ثماره
وله ثمرات وخيمه جدا ما هذه الثمرات ذكرها
الله قال ولا تجسس ولا يغتب بعضكم بعض هذه
كلها من ثمرات الظن
فان الظن
اذا وجد واستقر في القلب ظن السيء وظن
الاثم ظن الاثم
فانه
لا يلبث
كثيرا الا وياتي بهذه الثمار الوخيمه
يصبح يتحسس ويصبح يتجسس ويصبح
يتدابر ويصبح
يهم خاء ويصبح يتجسس عليه لماذا يريد ان
يتحقق من هذه الاهواء التي جرت فيه وهذه
الافكار الواهيه
فانه لا يتجسس متجسس حتى يظن السوء
صح ولا لا في حدا بيتجسس على ثاني الا وظن
السوء
بس
ظن بغيره يسوع ثم تجسس
ولذلك
التجسس من كبائر الذنوب في الاسلام
اكبر الكبائر اذا صدر من
الراعي
الذي هو مسؤول على المسلمين
يبتدا يتجسس على المسلمين فانه سيفسدهم
وهذا من اكبر الكبائر
هل تتصورون حكومه لا تتجسس على شعبها انا
اسالكم جد هل تتصور حكومه لا تتجسس على
شعبها
صعب جدا صح
ما في حكومه الا لو تتجسس على يعني عمرك
شفت حكومه ما تتجسس على شعبها
وهذه من ايات الساعه
من ايات الساعه كانت في حكومات كافره لا
تتجسس على شعبها
نعم
هذا من اخبث الخبث في حكومه او في جهه
حاكما تتجسس
انها تتجسس على الرعيه فلا يجوز حتى بعض
العلماء ذكر انه لا يجوز حتى في الجرائم
وانما يكون الامر بايش
التعامل مع الجرائم بعد ما تطلع طبعا هذه
مساله
يعني ثم اشياء فيها قد
يجتهد فيها العلماء
لان الله عز وجل
جعل التجسس بين المؤمنين
واما التجسس على العدو
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ارسل عيوننا
على اعدائه على اعدائه لكن ما حصل ابدا مع
مسلم ما صار ولا مره
من كان اكبر عدو للرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم في المدينه
اكبر عدو للرسول في المدينه
وهذا اجمع
اجمع كل المسلمين وكل
اهل زمان على كفر هذا الشخص
وعبد الله بن ابي بن سلول صح راس
المنافقين
ما في حدا بيكره الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم اكثر منه في زمنه
وليش ليش يكرهوا كان اعداء الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم في مكه
يكفرون به
ويحبونه حبا طبيعيا صح ولا لا لكن يكفرون
به
ويبغضون وبغضا شرعيا هذا جعلهم كافرين
وهذا
دخل في الاسلام
ظاهرا لكن في الباطن ان المنافقين في
الدرك الاسفل من النار
لماذا
لانه كان
كان في المدينه
يتوج كاد ان يكون ملك المدينه ملك يثرب
كان الكل يحترمه ويحبه
فاجى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم مهاجرا
وفي
نظريته خرب عليه الطبخ كلها
كيف يتنافس الحين مع رسول ياتيه الوحي من
الله
فكان اخبث الخبثاء ما الذي دفعوا على ذلك
نفس دافع لدافع ابليس
هل كان خيرا قبل ذلك
ومن اهل الخير قبل ذلك
لكنقلبت عليه هذه
المعصيه وهذه هذا الخبث
ارداه والعياذ بالله نفس ابليس ابليس ما
ما كان عنده خير قبل
قبل الكفر بالله كان في الجنه
لان مع الملائكه
صح ولا لا
واثقلنا للملائكه اسجدوا
اجمع العلماء على ان ابليس عليه السلام
عليه السلام على ان ابليس عليه لعنه الله
كان من المخاطبين بهذا الامر
للملائكه تسجدوا
فسجدوا الا ابليس
طيب ومش من الملائكه لكن من من جمله
الملائكه حكما
حكما
ان كان عنده خير من اول ايوه كان عنده خير
وعباده وتقوى وكل هذه الاشياء لكن كان فيه
بذره بذره شو ما طهر قلبه منها والزكي من
زكاه الله
ماذا كان من امره
جاء السبب المخرج لهذا الشر والسوء فانقلب
والعياذ بالله ولذلك الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم كان كثيرا ما يقول
يا مقلب القلوب ثبت قلبي على دينك ممكن
يحصل لاي واحد فينا
ان القلوب بين اصبعين من اصابع الرحمن
يقلبها كيف يشاء
نقيم رحمه الله يقول في نونياته ولو شاء
ربك كنت ايضا مثلهم فان القلوب بين اصابع
الرحمن
على كل حال غار من الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وحسده
وابتدا يعمل ضده في كل شيء في كل شيء
لا يترك له كلمه الا وله تعقيب وتعقير على
هذه الكلمه
حتى جاء راكبا عليه الصلاه والسلام فلما
جاء اليه قال
هذا هذه
يعني هذه
الراكبه تبعتك كانت بغله يركبها رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم ان رائحتها نتن وابتعد
عني منها ومش عارف ايش
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم تاذى هل يشك فيه
عداوه هذا الشخص لا يشك فيها هل تجسس عليه
ولا مره وكان ابنه من اكبر الصحابه لو قال
لابنه بس خبرني ابوك شو بسوي
هل يستفيد من ذلك
يستفيد صح هل فعل فعل
طيب الذي قتل عمر
هو توعد عمر
اليوم اللي قبله قبل ما نطعن عمر وقتله
صار بينه وبين كلام
ابو لؤلؤه المجوسي
وتوعد عمر
وعمر علم انه
يهدده علم ذلك
لكن
هل ارسل حرس وناس يتجسسوا عليه ويشوفوا
خبروني عنف لا لانه ما كان جبان
لانه ما كان جبان
والذي صفه صفه
الذي يغلب على اهل التجسس الضعف
والضعف النفسيه
والجبن
نفسيه رديئه تتجسس على الناس لذلك الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم منع هذا الشيء
وما كانت في حكومه مسلمه تتجسس على شعبها
الا لما دخل الفساد في الحكومات الاسلاميه
فان في عصر الصحابه ما في اشي اسمه متجسس
في اشي اسمه احنا بنسترك
نجارك يعرف انك تعمل شيء
خاطئ او انت
يعني كان
احدهم جاره يشرب الخمر ويفعل ويفعل ويقول
سادعو له الشرط فينهاه
غيره ويقول لا تفعل بل عظم واستر عليهم ما
تحكي لحدا ما تدخل الشرطه في القصه هاي
بما سالب سوها في دارهم اصبر عليهم عسى
الله اني اديهم
لانك اذا رحت كشفت عنه كيف بده يتوب بعديك
تعال سوق تبيه تهمه الان خلاص لا تنفك عنه
حتى لو تاب مئه توبه
ونكمل ان شاء الله غدا الله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا